welcome to this video audiosurf or
something brazil many Brazilian players
see em running um and I have never
played in before okay let's have some
fun I hope with the Evans gambit an
opening where I really only know one
line for white for black my defense
against this opening I do know of course
but that's it if they do something like
that I'm pretty much out of out of book
immediately yeah probably this is one
idea of all this young getting getting a
big big rook left going hmm maybe that's
not the idea the big rock lift hmm if I
go yeah how crazy is rook g3 very crazy
problem but 94 I possibly have Queen f
three years okay let's let's have some
some fun here it looks really weird you
can definitely just cancel track okay it
didn't want to Castle track so yeah here
I mean I don't know he didn't know what
that is I thought maybe 22 here I Scott
defife yeah I didn't really think about
that that that much
hmm I wonder should I really go to g1 or
maybe this is actually better 93 have to
go Queen f3 any way to make any sense
out of that I can just save the night I
completely ignored that I what really
completely ok so I have to do something
with Bishop e3 here preventing him from
castling and mikey is only one yeah he
cannot castle what game what a game hook
f-14 rook everyone and G for this is the
kind of thing I want to get in in a
practical game this is not even that
easy objectively speaking I'm certainly
lost but I don't think it is that easy
to play for him
you
a g4 I mean g4 is a threat it's all
somewhat ridiculous what I played in
this up to now but it's not so easy not
so easy to play okay so he covers five
how do I continue is still cannot cancel
and he has no quick way to prepare
canceling ok so maybe here I also to
cover to cover the bishop 94 I can play
Queen h5 check yeah I can do this Queen
invasion queen age 5 queen age 6 he has
queen is seven of course maybe look
everyone now I know I thought night 22
if form could be the way to go on or b6
actually be 6v6 c6 Bishop takes c6
Wow yeah this is some not easy this
position for him I mean really not pawn
takes Knight b5 is immediate win for
white remarkable what a crazy came look
a 3g three yeah but I came have to to do
something crazy once in a while
what is this actually see 6 i'm going to
take and then t on the eighth can he
still tied down thinking c6 Bishop takes
bc Quincy 6 check what is this move ads
it's ridiculous am queen d7 Queen a time
even ready for Queen d5 check and cares
of counseling I think black isn't
trouble him I really don't see what is
movers him this should be six somewhat
something like that i can take b7 and
this looks like it falls apart what
simply bishop is six mb take see 495 the
debtor nonius is really worth a lot we
take see now come on taking on d5 is
losing efore IM bishop flv for have
Queen f4 for the pin and I'm threatening
9 p-5 yeah so what about this can take
here then d 6 then be seven then it can
cancel
can also just take b7 Knight takes Queen
takes yeah but it's a whole look I can
take the whole look here and I hope
yeah it's a complete rock not just an
exchange or something night see form
this is maybe an idea okay let's play
temple moves to track trading down to
the piece of endgame yeah that was
really really crazy stuff black resign
Jeff probably will find multiple ways
for him to get to win yet this is this
is a known line I guess but I have to
just play see three NT for something
something like that should be a should
be normal and this is probably not
really a good hedge here yeah 94 was
what i was thinking then I planned
queena three which is probably
ridiculous it is it is because of d5
rook g7 bishop is six and it all looks
very very weird yeah well it took a here
and this is in fact not that clear yeah
comp gives wide and edge here amazingly
funny lines cute and TM computer just
wants to play htx g3 yeah hmm yeah there
is yeah can do that and here this is not
good because o green edge for Wow
gathered at to move that you can easily
miss him but it's a strong the text this
and hear each other and it was like that
I mean I'm just completely out of moves
now
I have no no nothing yeah this would
have fled out one from twin edge from i
mean i can try to try to stir up trouble
but there really is no attack him no and
this was the decisive moment maybe I
don't know here I don't know yeah the
computer says black is winning but in a
human game this is not easy at all not
easy at all comps s 94 wins yeah but it
did I see it really why is this
necessarily winning Teague's because III
Hanks or yeah okay this was a critical
come this was this was more than
critical yeah the only move that's not
losing everything is screen to do one
okay and quaint early one is basically
the same as resigns now this move yeah
that's good for wide at least something
I evaluated correctly queen d 7 s what
the compounds player GIM winning sled
out winning no here I'm not winning hmm
what is it what the compounds to do it
wants to take here and then here okay
let's still this end that's even better
and this wasn't so clear if he takes now
here and this I was thinking that this
should be really really good it may be
is good but it's just 0.8 or something
they are 0.8 so not to flat-out win okay
and here i would just had a head rook
yeah this was a very lucky very lucky
game but if you play this super
aggressive stuff but sometimes irritates
people to no end so I don't know okay I
hope you like that thanks for watching